David Boder: [In English] Paris, September the 8th ’46, in a suburb of Paris, Bellevue, a childrens’ home of the OPEJ. Spool Number 148. The interviewee is Ms. Lena Kuechler, 34 years old, who is the leader of a group of children which she brought in the number of 60, together with some 12 adults from Poland.
David Boder: Also, Fräulein Kuechler, wollen Sie uns wieder sagen, wie heißen Sie, wo sind Sie geboren und was für Ausbildung haben Sie gehabt?
Lena Kuechler: Ich bin geboren in Wieliczka Nähe Krakau. Das ist vierzehn Kilometer von Krakau. Ich hab studiert auf der Universität in Krakau. Auf der Jagelonischen Universität habe ich studiert...
David Boder: Welche Universität?
Lena Kuechler: Jagelonischen Universität.
David Boder: Jagelonischen Universität.
Lena Kuechler: Das ist eine uralte Universität aus dem 14. Jahrhundert. Dort habe ich mich spezialisiert in Pädagogik und Psychologie. Ich bin Magister of Psychologie. Vor dem Krieg habe ich unterrichtet in einer Schule, in einer jüdischen Schule in [unverständlich], sieben Jahre. Dann, während des Krieges, habe ich gekämpft in Warschau.
David Boder: Also [unverständlich] gemacht. Wer waren ihre Eltern, Fräulein Kuechler?
Lena Kuechler: Mein Vater war, heißt Elja Kuechler. Und meine Mutter Sara [unverständlich] Brenner.
David Boder: Ja. Brenner?
Lena Kuechler: Brenner, ja.
David Boder: Ja, nun. Wo sind Ihre Eltern?
Lena Kuechler: Meine Eltern sind gestorben. Meine Mutter ist drei Monate vor dem Krieg gestorben und meinen Vater haben die Deutschen getötet.
David Boder: Was heißt getötet?
Lena Kuechler: Er wurde getötet in 42. Jahr. Er war krank im Bett. Sie sind reingekommen ins Zimmer und sie haben ihn, und sie haben ihn im Bett geschossen.
David Boder: Gleich in Krakau? Und wo waren Sie?
Lena Kuechler: In Wieliczka.
David Boder: In Wieliczka. Und wo waren Sie?
Lena Kuechler: Ich war in der selben, ich war im ersten Jahr, war ich im [unverständlich], im ersten Jahr im [unverständlich].
David Boder: Ja, aber ich wollte wissen, wer hat das gesehen, dass die Deutschen Ihren Vater getötet haben?
Lena Kuechler: Ja, mit meinem Vater war nur meine Schwester, die leider auch gefallen ist. Sieben Tage vor der Liberation ist gefallen. Das hat gesehen eine alte Polin, die bei uns Dienst gemacht hat.
David Boder: Aha.
Lena Kuechler: Sie hat das gesehen.
David Boder: Aha, wer waren das, die Deutschen oder die Ukrainer? Wer war...
Lena Kuechler: Das waren Leute, das war ein Gestapo.
David Boder: Ein Gestapo.
Lena Kuechler: Das war der [unverständlich] in Wieliczka. Der [unverständlich].
David Boder: Also, also den Tod Ihres Vaters hat eine Polin gesehen, die bei Ihnen im Hause gearbeitet hat?
Lena Kuechler: Ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Lena Kuechler: Die Polin lebt noch, jetzt. Sie ist in Wieliczka. Und sie kann das immer noch erzählen.
David Boder: Ja, nun äh. Also, wo waren Sie zu dieser Zeit?
Lena Kuechler: Ich bin zu dieser Zeit gewesen in Warschau, zusammen mit meinem Mann.
David Boder: Aha. Sie waren verheiratet?
Lena Kuechler: Ich war verheiratet, ja. Aber ich hab nicht gelebt zusammen mit meinem Mann. Deshalb weil ich, äh ähnlich ein, eine Jüdin bin und mein Mann war weniger ähnlich zu einem Juden. Wir haben beide gelebt auf so genannten arische Papiere. Also er als Pole und ich als Polin. Wir haben extra gewohnt.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie, und was haben Sie dann getan? Was haben, was haben Sie durch diese Zeit getan?
Lena Kuechler: In Warschau war mir sehr schwer. Ich...
David Boder: Also Sie waren noch in Welice oder wie heißt der Ort?
Lena Kuechler: Wieliczka.
David Boder: Sie waren in Wieliczka. Und wo waren Sie von Wieliczka gegangen?
Lena Kuechler: Von Wieliczka bin ich gegangen nach Warschau.
David Boder: Ja.
Lena Kuechler: Und...
David Boder: Was haben Sie dort getan?
Lena Kuechler: Und in Warschau wollte, wollte ich äh, hab ich schon andere Papiere gehabt, nicht wahr. Arische Papiere und dort...
David Boder: Ja, und erzählen, erzählen Sie weiter?
Lena Kuechler: Und dort wollte ich mich irgendwie erhalten. Ich war in einer sehr schweren Lage, ich hab kein Geld gehabt, ich musste verdienen, um zu leben. Aber es war sehr, äh sehr. Ich konnte überhaupt nicht, ich konnte auf die Straße nicht herausgehen, denn ich, auf jeden Schritt und Tritt war [unverständlich] hatten wir gewartet. Ich musste [unverständlich].
David Boder: Was nennen Sie [unverständlich]?
Lena Kuechler: Ich kann Ihnen eine kleine Szene erzählen, wie war erste [unverständlich].
David Boder: Ja, ja.
Lena Kuechler: Also ich habe, hab gearbeitet in einer Fabrik im Judenghetto als gewöhnliche Arbeiterin. Um 4 Uhr bin ich nach Haus gegangen. In dieser Fabrik waren sehr viele Juden noch. Sie sind vom Ghetto gekommen auf die arische Seite und dort haben wir zusammen gearbeitet.
David Boder: Das war erlaubt für die Juden zu kommen? Ja.
Lena Kuechler: Die Juden sind gekommen unter einer Eskorte. Immer mit einem Gestapo-Mann sind sie gekommen. Der ist gestanden bei diesen Juden und dann sind sie am Abend zurück nach Ghetto gegangen. Äh, ich bin in meiner Wohnung. Die Gestapo ist gegangen und da hat mich jemand angesprochen auf der Straße. Er war ein Pole. Er hat mir gesagt, ich bin eine Jüdin. Er hat das nicht gewusst, dass das stimmt, aber nach meinem Aussehen nach. Und er kennt mich und er verlangt, gesagt, dass er mich äh [unverständlich]. Wie sagt man auf?
David Boder: Ja, er wird Sie denunzieren.
Lena Kuechler: Er wird mich denunzieren auf Gestapo. Ich hab diese Sachen noch nicht gekannt, aber trotzdem hab ich den Mut nicht verloren. Ich hab ihm gesagt, das ist ja nicht wahr, dass er lügt und wenn er mich nach Gestapo führen will, würde, es wird umgekehrt sein. Ich werd ihn führen und ich hab ihn einem polnischen Polizisten äh gebeten und aufgefordert, äh dass man mir keine Ruhe gibt und so weiter und dass. Und der polnische Polizist hat ihn seine Pa..., hat ihn...
David Boder: ... seine Papiere verlangt.
Lena Kuechler: Hat von ihm seine Papiere verlangt und von mir meine mit Brief und so weiter. Hat, er hat mir verschiedene Fragen gestellt. Hat er, bei dieser Sache hab ich mich ganz schön blamiert, denn er hat mich gefragt, wie heißen meine Eltern. Hab ich den Namen meines Vaters vergessen, denn des des...
David Boder: Des falschen Vaters
Lena Kuechler: Meines falschen Vaters, denn das waren doch nicht meine...
David Boder: Eltern
Lena Kuechler: ... wahre Eltern. Meine wirkliche Eltern, aber trotz alledem hab ich gesagt, ich bin keine Jüdin und äh, ich äh lass mich nicht [unverständlich]. Dass der Mensch wollte noch Geld verdienen und ich hab ihm nichts gegeben. Damals hab ich, er hat. Der Polizist wusste nicht, was er machen soll mit uns alle beiden. Hat er gesagt, er kenne. Er hat sich aufgeschrieben unsere Adressen, nicht wahr. Und dann hat er uns gesagt, wir sollen gehen. Er wird dies nachher schon weiter...
David Boder: ... untersuchen...
Lena Kuechler: ... untersuchen. Aber dann hab ich mich noch, dieselbe Stunde habe ich noch meine Wohnung [unverständlich]. Das war eine sehr schwere Sache, das war eine Wohnung zu finden, nicht war. Aber da hab ich auf der Straße, paar Tage da war ich auf der Straße bis zum nächsten [unverständlich].
David Boder: Nun, und äh Sie sagen, Sie waren auf der Straße, waren Sie in der Nacht auf der Straße?
Lena Kuechler: Ich war auch in der Nacht auf der Straße.
David Boder: Aber es war doch aber verboten rauszugehen am Abend oder?
Lena Kuechler: Ja, da bin ich gegangen äh. Es war, wie heißt das, in der elektrische war ich. Am Bahnhof war ich. So hab ich...
David Boder: Wo denn Leute in der Nacht rumgehen?
Lena Kuechler: Ja.
David Boder: Also weiter.
Lena Kuechler: Einmal ich hab gewohnt in Warschau auf der Straße Nowogrodzka [unverständlich] bei einer polnischen Familie...
David Boder: Also, haben die gewusst, dass Sie Jüdin sind?
Lena Kuechler: Niemand hat gewusst, dass ich Jüdin bin. Denn wenn sie das gewusst hätten, hätten sie keine Jüdin äh genommen. Ganz umgekehrt. Sie haben keine, sie haben Angst gehabt zuerst und dann haben sie mich kennen gelernt, die Juden. Sie haben den Juden nicht geholfen, doch. Also ich war, ich hab damals gearbeitet bei Julius Meine in der Zentrale als Buchhalterin. Es war ein Mode dort zu arbeiten, denn es war eine deutsche Firma, aber ich musste wovon leben und äh dann hab ich gemeint, nicht, wahr, ich wär dort gedeckt. Also ich hab mich hingelegt schlafen. Doch circa 12 Uhr in der Nacht seh ich, äh hör ich äh verschiedene Stimmen und Licht ist da. Ein Gestapo-Polizist steht bei mir mit ein Revolver und er sagt mir, Hände hoch. Also in der Nacht hat er mir, hat er mich geführt in ein Zimmer und dort waren versammelt alle, äh die gewohnt haben in der Wohnung und sie haben jemanden gesucht. Und sie haben alle Leute dafür gesucht. Zu mir ist gekommen der Gestapo-Polizist. Und er hat mir gleich gesagt, Sie sind bestimmt eine Jüdin.
David Boder: Also weiter, was ht dann passiert?
Lena Kuechler: Dann es hat mir nix geholfen. Er hat mir gesagt, ich soll mich ganz weiß anziehen. Er hat niemanden vom Haus genommen, sondern mich. Und vier Männer haben mich genommen. Sie haben mich auf Gestapo geführt, auf [unverständlich]. Dort wenn jemand herein gekommen ist, ist er nicht mehr herausgekommen. Ich hab damals noch keinen Gift gehabt bei mir. Deshalb war mir sehr schwer, denn wenn ich Gift hätte, hätte ich keine Angst mehr. Ich hab vor dem Tod keine Angst niemals gehabt. Ich wollte nur nicht dass sie mich dort, dort [unverständlich]. Und wenn ich ein Gift hätte, hätte ich das genommen. Und sie kommen nicht dazu mich, äh, mich dort zu quälen die Gestapo. Also habe ich mir gedacht, der Tod ist immer besser als man dort mich [unverständlich] jeden Tag zu quälen. [unverständlich] Es war in der Nacht, vier haben mich geführt. Zwei, ich bin gegangen in der Mitte. Zwei dicke Polizisten, Gestapo-Leute, sind gegangen vor mir und zwei hinter mir. Alles mit Bajonett, mit aufgestelltem Bajonett. Wir sind gegangen zur Gestapo. Es war mir kalt. Egal, ich habe keine Angst gehabt. Äh ich hab mir, ich hab mir nur gedacht, was mach ich, was mach ich? Wenn ich einen Revolver hätte, hätte ich alle erschossen. Wie sollen sie mich dann erschießen? [unverständlich] Dann sind wir gekommen, wo die Allee schon war, es war schon das Tor. Ich wusste, dass wenn ich hereinkomme, gehe ich niemals heraus. [unverständlich]
David Boder: Welche zwei?
Lena Kuechler: Zwei, die vor mir gegangen sind, zwei Polizisten.
David Boder: Polizisten.
Lena Kuechler: ... sind in Tor herein gegangen.
David Boder: Ja.
Lena Kuechler: Und jetzt wollte ich hereinkommen. Und zwei hinter mir. Auf einmal dreh ich mich um und ich fang an zulaufen. Also die zwei laufen nicht mir nach, sie schießen. Ich weiß nicht, ich erinnere mich nicht mehr. Ich weiß, es war ein Zufall, ein vorbei geflogen, den ich nicht kannte.
David Boder: Ein Wunder.
Lena Kuechler: Ein Wunder, dass sie mich nicht getroffen haben. Ich hab [unverständlich] nach rechts nach links, die Kugeln sind so bei mir...
David Boder: ... vorbei geflogen.
Lena Kuechler: ... vor, vor vorbei geflogen, aber keine hat mich nicht angerührt. Und dann bin ich gleich um die Ecke gegangen und gelaufen und gelaufen. Die Poli..., die Gestapo-Leute haben nicht, haben sich keine große Mühe mit mir gegeben. Sie haben, sie waren, sind nicht mir nachgelaufen. Sie haben geschossen. Sie haben geglaubt vielleicht, dass ich bin gefallen. Und dann sind sie weiter gegangen und eine Weile bin ich an der Ecke geblieben. Aber das dann war immer dieselbe Waffe. Ich war schon [unverständlich] in ganz Warschau, denn ich war schon auf sieben. Wie heißt das...
Lena Kuechler: [In Polish] ...posterunek policji...
David Boder: [In German] In sieben Polizeistationen.
Lena Kuechler: In sieben Polizeistationen in verschiedenen Ecken [unverständlich] Ecken in Warschau. Und dreimal war ich [unverständlich]. Das war schon das dritte Mal, ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Lena Kuechler: Ich konnte nicht mehr bleiben in Warschau. Ich wurde [unverständlich]. Es ist mir ganz klar gewesen, dass weiter kann das schon nicht mehr gehen. Hab ich gedacht, ich muss herausfahren aus Warschau. Ich hab Annoncen in verschiedene Zeitungen gelesen, studiert und eine Annonce hab ich gefunden. Man suchte eine Erzieherin für Kinder äh aufs Land ziemlich weit von Warschau. Die haben mir gesagt, ich [unverständlich] ein kleiner Säugling. [unverständlich] ich nicht gesehen werd. Ich werd auch nicht alleine sein, nur mit Kinder. Dort will ich schauen.
David Boder: Bis man weiter kommt.
Lena Kuechler: Ja, bis man weiter kommt. Ich hab die Annonce, ich bin gegangen auf diese Adresse. Ich hab mich bei der Frau gemeldet. Ich hab ihr ziemlich gut gefallen und eine Sache hat sie mir gesagt, dass sie hat sehr viel Kandidatinnen für diesen Posten gehabt, aber sie, die Frauen haben ihr nicht gefallen und dann sie [unverständlich] hat sie gesagt, die Frauen schauen ihr zu ähnlich wie Jüdinnen und deshalb hat sie sie nicht genommen und mich hat sie genommen. Es war mir unangenehm [unverständlich], dass ich lügen muss, aber ich wollte doch auch weiter leben. Und dann ich hab geglaubt, dass es [unverständlich] gar nix [unverständlich].
David Boder: Und dann...
Lena Kuechler: Auf so eine Weise hab ich einen Posten bekommen, dort, und dort bei einem kleinen sieben Monate [unverständlich] Kind.
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Lena Kuechler: Sieben Monate.
David Boder: Also Sie waren in der Wohnung mit?
Lena Kuechler: Ja, ich war in der Wohnung bei dem Kind, ich hab geschlafen mit dem Kind. Ich war, bin sehr gern gekommen, hab sehr geliebt das Kind. Und ich war dort ein Jahr. Und ja.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie, wenn man so in eine polnische Familie als Polin lebt, haben Sie nicht die Religion verstehen müssen?
Lena Kuechler: Es war mir sehr schwer.
David Boder: Ja.
Lena Kuechler: Die Leute haben die ganze Zeit mich observiert.
David Boder: Ja, haben sie Sie beobachtet?
Lena Kuechler: Sie haben mich beobachtet. Ich, sie hatten, ich hab nur Acht gegeben, auf alles, auf meine polnische Sprache. Es durften keine Ausdrücke sein, die die Juden gebrauchen.
David Boder: Hmm.
Lena Kuechler: Ich soll keine äh, wie heißt das, mit den Händen nicht so viel...
David Boder: ... reden
Lena Kuechler: ... reden.
David Boder: Ja.
Lena Kuechler: Und nicht das, aber auf jeden Schritt und Tritt, ich musste eine Maske haben, den ganzen Tag und die ganze Nacht. Und trotz alledem die Leute, die Leute haben, waren nicht gefährlich. Ich war nicht ganz ähnlich einer Polin, aber ich war auch keiner Jüdin ähnlich. Sie haben eine sehr schlechte Meinung über Juden gehabt [unverständlich] nicht arbeiten, nicht arbeiten wollen, dass sie schmutzig sind, dass sie ein schlechtes Aussehen haben, dass sie nicht sehr intelligent sind und so weiter. Bei mir haben sie das nicht gefunden. Ich hab das dort sehr gut gearbeitet, sehr rein gearbeitet. Und sie, eigentlich war ich die beste Kraft, die sie je [unverständlich] hatten. Also das hat ihnen nicht gepasst, dass eine Jüdin. Sie haben nicht geglaubt, dass eine Jüdin [unverständlich] arbeiten kann und rein sein kann, [unverständlich] und gut erzogen und sich benehmen beim Tisch und in Gesellschaft. Also das hat mich gerettet, nicht wahr. Und das bezüglich der Religion wollte ich nicht in die Kirche gehen. Ich habe niemals getan. In der ganzen Zeit bin ich nicht einmal in die Kirche gegangen. Trotz aller Gefahr. Trotzdem dass, äh dass man immer in einem Dorf, [unverständlich] wenn jemand nicht in die Kirche geht das geht gar nicht. Bestimmt hat er ein [unverständlich]. Aber ich wollte das alles nicht. Ich habe gesagt, ich bin [unverständlich] getauft [unverständlich]. Und sie, die Leute haben mir das übel gehalten, aber es war wie meine Chefin hat das verstanden und sie hat mich nicht gezwungen dazu. Sie hat gesagt, nun ja, die Frau, Fräulein Lena hab ich geheißen dort, Sie sind eine gute Kraft, es wäre besser, wenn Sie mehr [unverständlich]. Dann kann man nichts machen.
David Boder: Ja, aber sagen Sie, äh, haben Sie nicht dann und wann selbst über Juden gesprochen? Haben Sie nicht Ihre Meinung gesagt über die Juden?
Lena Kuechler: Ja, die Leute haben sehr oft über Juden gesprochen und es waren verschiedene Meinungen über Juden. Es war sogar vom psychologischen Standpunkt sehr interessant, was die Leute von, über die Juden gesprochen haben. Also es war eine Zeit, wo man, das Dorf, wo ich gewesen bin, da war nicht weit von einem [unverständlich] Todlager [unverständlich].
David Boder: Vernichtungslager?
Lena Kuechler: Vernichtungslager von Treblinka.
David Boder: Oh.
Lena Kuechler: Treblinka. Ich war vielleicht zwanzig Kilometer von Treblinka. Also dort sind diese alle Transporte gefahren und wir haben getroffen Juden, die ganz verrückt schon waren. Solche Arme. Ich konnte, ich hab soviel damals gelitten. Ich hab in meinem Leben nicht gelitten. Ich hab nicht gelitten damals, als mir [unverständlich] geschossen hat. Ich hab nicht soviel gelitten wie damals, wenn ich gesehen diese arme Juden, ich wollte nicht sehen. Es war [unverständlich]. Es war [unverständlich]. Ja. Ein bisschen hat man doch Herz gehabt. Man hat gesagt, die armen Juden, aber dann ist aufgestanden und hat gesagt, man kann doch mit den Juden nicht anders fertig werden. Man muss alle erschießen. Oder muss man ihnen eine vollkommene Freiheit geben oder muss man sie erschießen. Und ich hab der Junge, wie heißt das, [unverständlich] der, dieser, der Eigentümer des, es war ein Graf, der hat gesagt, und ich bin der Meinung, es ist besser, dass man das ganze Volk vernichtet. [unverständlich]
David Boder: Ist der Graf bei Ihnen im Hause verkehrt? Wieso sind sie...
Lena Kuechler: Ja, ich war in einem Haus von einem Graf.
David Boder: Oh, Sie waren in einem Hause von einem Graf?
Lena Kuechler: Ja, ja. Von einem Graf, ja.
David Boder: Aha.
Lena Kuechler: Es war eine, so eine aristokratische polnische Familie. [unverständlich]
David Boder: Ja, nun.
Lena Kuechler: Ich war [unverständlich]. Der Graf war der Besitzer und seine Schwester hat das Kind gehabt, [unverständlich] arbeiten war. Die Schwester, meine Chefin, die war eigentlich eine Freundin. Und sie hat gesagt, ihr tun die Juden leid. Sie hat immer Sympathie mit den Juden gehabt. Aber trotz alledem, was sie gesagt hat, trotz alledem die Juden sind nicht viel wert, dass man mit ihnen sympathisiert. Und dann hab ich gedacht, dann sei sie ein undankbares Element [unverständlich] sollen wir ihnen helfen, aber nach dem Krieg, dann werden sie kommen alle Leute auf uns. [unverständlich] gesagt schon, wie Freundinnen [unverständlich] wie sehr große Freundinnen waren. Nun ja, äh also ich habe verschiedene Meinungen gehört über die Juden. Im Allgemeinen waren sie alle große [unverständlich]. Ich hab mir nicht einmal gedacht, was wäre erst, wenn sie einmal [unverständlich].
David Boder: Nun, und wie lange hat das gedauert?
Lena Kuechler: Ich war bei diesen Leuten bis Ende des Krieges, bis die Russen, bis die Russen gekommen sind. Aber dann, wenn die Russen gekommen sind, dann hat man ihnen das ganze Gut verteilt, parzelliert.
David Boder: Sie sind noch dort gewesen?
Lena Kuechler: Ich war noch dort gewesen.
David Boder: Ja...
Lena Kuechler: ... und...
David Boder: Sind Sie dort geblieben?
Lena Kuechler: Ich ... also der Graf ist weggelaufen.
David Boder: Ja.
Lena Kuechler: Aber seine Schwester, das meine Chefin, von der ich gesagt habe, sie war wie eine Freundin, sie war
David Boder: ... besser...
Lena Kuechler: ... besser, ja. Sie ist geblieben, allein mit vier Kindern. Zwei waren ihre Kinder, das waren meine...
David Boder: Schützlinge...
Lena Kuechler: Schützlinge. Und zwei Kinder von der Familie von Warschau. Also sie ist geblieben. Und man hat ihr alles weggenommen. Nicht einmal Kartoffeln gegeben. Gar nichts. Sie hat ein [unverständlich] Leben gehabt. Und ich bin von Beruf Lehrerin, hab ich gegründet in diesem Dorf eine Schule. Ich bin gegangen zum Kommissar. Sie wussten alle noch nicht, dass ich Jüdin bin. Ich hab ihm vor, ich hab ihn, ich hab ihn gebeten, er soll mir helfen eine Schule dort gründen für die [unverständlich] Kinder...
David Boder: Im Dorf.
Lena Kuechler: ... im Schloss. Und auf seine Weise ich hab, ich hab dort gewohnt im Schloss. Weil ich Direktorin der Schule war, ich hab dort unterrichtet und ich hab gebeten, man soll erlauben der Frau mit diesen vier Kindern auch zusammen mit mir in einem Zimmer wohnen und ich habe die Leute erhalten sechs Monate. Die haben mich nicht [unverständlich] Leben gehabt, von meinem Gehalt als Lehrerin hab ich die ganze Familie erhalten.
David Boder: Aber die Russen haben ihnen gezahlt.
Lena Kuechler: Die Russen haben mir gezahlt und auch die Kinder, die Eltern haben etwas gebracht immer. Milch haben die gebracht.
David Boder: Die polnische Eltern...
Lena Kuechler: Die polnische Eltern, die waren, die haben mich sehr gern gehabt und die Kinder haben sehr viel profitiert in der Schule. Da war schon ein paar Jahre keine Schule. Die Kinder haben nicht lesen, nicht...
David Boder: ... schreiben
Lena Kuechler: ... schreiben können. Die Eltern auch nicht. Ich hab sehr viel gearbeitet und sie haben mich überhaupt im Dorf sehr gern gehabt.
David Boder: Aber haben die gewusst, dass Sie Jüdin sind?
Lena Kuechler: Die haben nicht gewusst, dass ich Jüdin bin.
David Boder: Nicht bis zum Ende?
Lena Kuechler: Nein, bis zu Ende haben sie nicht gewusst, dass ich Jüdin bin. Denn trotz alledem waren die Leute Antisemiten. Es wäre mir sehr schwer. Ich hab gewartet [unverständlich] bleiben so lang bis ich nach Warschau [unverständlich]. In Warschau ist mein Mann geblieben und meine Schwester geblieben. Das sind die letzen Leute von meiner Familie, die dort geblieben sind. Also ich wollte zurück nach Warschau gehen und auch suchen die Leute [unverständlich].
David Boder: Nun, und Sie haben auch der Schwester des Grafen nicht gesagt, dass Sie Jüdin waren bis zum Ende?
Lena Kuechler: Nein. Es war so, es war eine merkwürdige psychologische Szene. Die Schwester des Grafen hat auch ihre Schwester und ihren Mann in Warschau gehabt und ich auch. Aber sie hat nicht gewusst, dass ich verheiratet bin. Und sie hat nicht gewusst, dass ich eine Schwester habe. Ich wollte dann wenn Warschau schon, äh...
David Boder: ... frei war...
Lena Kuechler: ... frei war, wollte ich nach Warschau gehen. Denn es waren keine Züge, es war achtzig Kilometer von Warschau, aber trotz alledem wollte ich gehen, denn ich habe einen schrecklichen Traum von meiner Schwester gehabt, dass sie nicht lebt. Also ich wollte sie suchen. Hat sie gesagt, wozu ich denn nach Warschau geh. Ich werd zuerst gehen und bleiben Sie bei den Kindern. Ich hab doch meinen Mann und meine Schwester. Sie haben doch niemanden zu suchen. [unverständlich] aufgehalten und ich hab gesagt, ja, ich hab genau dasselbe. Ich hab auch einen Mann und eine Schwester in Warschau. Hat sie gesagt, wieso? Hab ich ihr gesagt, ich bin Jüdin. Also dann, das war schon am Ende. Ich weiß nicht, ihr Verhältnis war genauso dann wie früher. Aber sie hat sich nicht einmal überzeugt, was für ein [unverständlich] ich bin. Ich bin nicht so wie sie gesagt hat undankbar. Die Leute haben mir keine Ungnaden gemacht, denn sie haben nicht gewusst, dass ich Jüdin bin. Ich hab schwer gearbeitet und sehr gehungert bei den Leuten. Und die haben mir...
David Boder: Wieso haben Sie gehungert?
Lena Kuechler: Ich hab gehungert, ja.
David Boder: Warum?
Lena Kuechler: Sie, die Leute [unverständlich] gegeben. Ich war immer hungrig. Ich...
David Boder: In einem Dorf ist doch genug zu essen...
Lena Kuechler: Die Leute, die Leute haben, es war, es war ein, das war, es war ein, wie heißt das? Ei, Ein... Dort war keine einzige Kuh in dem ganzen Dorf. Sie haben, ja, sie haben nicht viel gehabt. Und das was sie haben, haben sie auch verteilt, so dass sie sich mehr genommen haben und den Leuten, die im Dienst waren, die, denen haben sie nicht viel gegeben. Also ich hab buchstäblich gehungert. Ich war 42 Kilo hab ich gewogen.
David Boder: ... gewogen. Als sie beim Grafen gearbeitet haben?
Lena Kuechler: Ja, damals.
David Boder: Und dennoch haben Sie [unverständlich] nachher unterstützt.
Lena Kuechler: Ich hab sie erhalten, wirklich erhalten, sechs Monate. Die ganze Familie, vier Kinder und die Frau. Ich hab sie erhalten. Und nicht nur das. Aber ich hab ihnen sehr viel [unverständlich]. Ich hab ihnen gerettet 17 Hektar der Erde, denn ich hab gesorgt...
David Boder: Wieso?
Lena Kuechler: das soll, das war ein Garten, man soll es nicht verlieren. Es musste die Schule sein für die Kinder und das ist ihnen dann noch geblieben und der Garten und das Schloss ist jetzt ihnen geblieben. Ich hab ihnen das gerettet irgendwie. Also, die Leute haben nicht gewusst, dass ich Jüdin bin und [unverständlich]. Die Gräfin. Wenn sie gewusst hätten, dass ich Jüdin bin, hätten sie mich nicht behalten. Aber trotz alledem hab ich mich verpflichtet, den Leuten, wenn sie in Not, in Not waren äh helfen.
David Boder: Etwas für die zu tun.
Lena Kuechler: Ja, auch in Warschau. Bevor ich nach Frankreich gefahren bin, da hab ich mich gemeldet zu diesen Leuten. Sie sind sehr arm jetzt. Ich habe diese Frau geführt zu...
David Boder: Wie heißt sie?
Lena Kuechler: Pawłowski heißt sie.
David Boder: Ah, Pawłowski.
Lena Kuechler: Graf Pawłowski. Und die Frau nach ihrem Mann die heißt Jabłońska, Halina Jabłońska. Ich hab sie geführt zum Direktor des polnischen Joint – Guzik, der jetzt nicht lebt leider mehr, und ich hab ihm die Geschichte erzählt. Ich hab ihn gebeten, er soll ihnen und er hat ihnen geholfen mit verschiedene Produkte und Anzüge und so weiter und ich hab ihnen auch Geld gelassen und so weiter...
David Boder: Was heißt der polnische Joint? Der Joint ist ja eine jüdische Organisation.
Lena Kuechler: Ja, der Joint ist eine internationale jüdische Organisation. Aber in polnisch, In Polen ist er für die bislang.
David Boder: Ja, ist [unverständlich].
Lena Kuechler: Ja, ist ein [unverständlich].
David Boder: Und er hat ihnen geholfen.
Lena Kuechler: Er hat ihnen geholfen. Der Direktor Guzik hat den Leuten geholfen. Er hat damals vielen Polen, die den Juden äh, während der Zeit des Krieges geholfen haben, hat jetzt der Joint äh für diese Polen auch gemacht.
David Boder: Nun, also was haben Sie dann in Warschau gemacht? Haben Sie Ihre Schwester gefunden? Ich meine...
Lena Kuechler: Ich hab leider nicht meinen Mann gefunden und nicht meiner Schwester. Mit meiner Schwester war das eine schreckliche Tragödie. Ich hab sie nachgesucht, nachgesucht bis ich, bis ich getroffen hab, dass sie war in der letzten Zeit in Łowicz. Łowicz. Und dort das ist von Warschau... 40 Kilometer äh Westen.
David Boder: Ahem. Ja.
Lena Kuechler: Im Westen. Ja, das ist neben Łódź.
David Boder: Ja.
Lena Kuechler: Und dort hat Stefanie, meine Schwester, die dreiundzwanzig Jahre alt war. Die hat sich durchgerungen durch den ganzen Krieg. Die hat so viel mitgemacht, das man sich nicht vorstellen kann. Sie war im Ghetto mit, mit meinem Vater zusammen. Und dann hat sie gekämpft und sie war. Ich kann Ihnen das alles nicht erzählen, denn das wäre viel zu viel zu erzählen. Ich weiß, dass sie einiges mitgemacht hat und sie war dann in Warschau. Sie hat das ganze Bombardement durchgemacht. Sie hat mit den Polen gekämpft, wir haben zusammen. Alle beide waren wir zusammen, aber niemals zusammen gegangen, aber so heimlich gearbeitet zusammen in der unterirdischen polnischen Résistance-Bewegung haben wir gekämpft.
David Boder: Aber wann haben Sie in der Résistance gekämpft? Während sie bei den [unverständlich] lebten?
Lena Kuechler: Nein, nein. Ich...
David Boder: Noch bevor?
Lena Kuechler: Ja, bevor. Ja.
David Boder: Nun, also kommen Sie auf Ihre Schwester zurück.
Lena Kuechler: Ja, also ich, mit meiner Schwester ist in Łowicz gewesen. Sie war von Warschau ist sie zurückgegangen. Ja, weggelaufen und dort, in Łowicz hat sie gewohnt bei einer polnischen Familie und der Mann hat Verdacht gehabt, dass sie Jüdin. Ist er gegangen zur Gestapo und er hat gesagt, sie ist Jüdin. Und man ist gekommen von Gestapo, man hat sie genommen damals und man hat sie erschossen sieben Tage vor der Liberation. [unverständlich] in den Kopf bekommen. Das war der Lohn von Gestapo für einen jüdischen Kopf.
David Boder: Wieso haben sie das erfahren? Von wem haben Sie das erfahren?
Lena Kuechler: Ich hab das zufällig erfahren. Ich hab zwei, zwei [unverständlich]
David Boder: Zwei Zeugen gefunden...
Lena Kuechler: Zwei Zeugen dafür.
David Boder: Haben Sie den Mann nachher gefunden?
Lena Kuechler: Ich hab den Mann, ich weiß sogar, wie der Mann heißt. Er heißt [unverständlich], er wohnt in [unverständlich] und den Mann hab ich gefunden. Und mein Bruder, ich hab noch einen Bruder, der in Polen ist, der in der polnischen Regierung arbeitet. Ich hab ihn gebeten, er soll die Sache, die Sache erledigen. Ich habe [unverständlich] Ich bin auf die Polizei, die polnische gegangen. [unverständlich] Und ich habe ein Protokoll geschrieben. Ich habe diese Adressen angegeben alle und sie sollen den Mann verhaften. Ich weiß nicht, was sie erledigt haben, denn inzwischen bin ich herausgefahren mit allen meinen Kindern. Wir mussten herausfahren mit den Kindern, denn es hat ihnen sehr viel getroffen.
David Boder: Also, Sie sagen, Sie sind herausgefahren mit allen Ihren Kindern. Wollen Sie mir jetzt wissen während des Erzählens, wie sind Sie zu den Kindern gekommen, wo, wieso haben Sie diese Kinder? Sie sind in Warschau gewesen. Nun, wo haben Sie angefangen, diese Kinder zu sammeln? Wie haben Sie die Idee gehabt?
Lena Kuechler: Ja, nachdem als ich erfahren hab, dass meine Schwester lebt nicht und wahrscheinlich mein Mann lebt auch nicht. Dass er ist gefallen in Warschau, bin ich gefahren nach Krakau und Wieliczka. Wieliczka war auch die Stadt, in der ich geboren bin. Das ist vierzehn Kilometer von Krakau. Und ich habe jemanden gesucht von meiner Familie noch, denn ich hab noch vier Brüder gehabt. Da hab ich erfahren, ein Bruder ist gekommen von Russland. Er [unverständlich] ich hab jetzt gewartet [unverständlich]
David Boder: Ja.
Lena Kuechler: Also ich war sehr glücklich, dass ich meinen Bruder gefunden hab. Ich hab sehr gern den Bruder und der Bruder hat mir nicht erlaubt, mehr zurückkommen zu diesen Leuten, zu dieser Gräfin, nicht wahr. Ich wollte bleiben in Krakau. Ich wär mit ihm zusammen [unverständlich].
David Boder: Haben Sie denn in Warschau mit der Gräfin gelebt?
Lena Kuechler: Nein. Sie ist noch nicht damals zurückgekommen nach Warschau. Die Gräfin ist noch immer am Land geblieben, ja?
David Boder: Aha.
Lena Kuechler: Und ich hab mir Urlaub genommen von der Schule. Ich bin gegangen. Ich bin gefahren nach Krakau, um meine Familie zu suchen. Dann bin ich zurückgekommen noch einmal. Ich hab nicht [unverständlich] eine andere Lehrerin gesucht für die Schule und ich bin zurückgekommen nach Krakau und [unverständlich]. In Krakau bin ich gegangen auf die Universität. Zu meinem Professor, Professor der Uni, Universitätsprofessor Schumann, also das ist der Professor der Psychologie, bei dem ich die ganze Zeit gearbeitet hab.
David Boder: Früher?
Lena Kuechler: Früher, vor dem Krieg. Ich hab mein Studium beendet, habe ich weiter wissenschaftlich gearbeitet, in der Psychologie der Kinder, Entwicklungspsychologie der Kinder. Der Professor Schumann war in Dachau, aber trotzdem ist er lebendig herausgekommen.
David Boder: War er Jude?
Lena Kuechler: Er war nicht Jude, er war Pole.
David Boder: Warum war er in Dachau?
Lena Kuechler: Man hat alle polnischen Professoren der Universität nach Dachau, noch im 39. Jahr nach Dachau genommen.
David Boder: Warum?
Lena Kuechler: ... man wollte die ganze polnische Intelligenz [unverständlich] und ich bin zu ihm gekommen. Ich hab ihm gesagt, ich hab alles verloren. Ich will weiter wissenschaftlich arbeiten.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool, this concludes Spool 114 taken at Bellevue near Paris. In the home of the OPEJ, from the director of the home Lena Kuechler. We continue on the 15th.
David Boder: This is Spool 115, of Bellevue near Paris, September the 7th, September the 8th 1946. Ms. Lena Kuechler continues her report.
David Boder: [In German] Also Sie sagen, Sie, ich möchte jetzt die Geschichte haben von Ihrer Übersiedlung mit den Kindern. Wie haben Sie die Kinder gesammelt, wie hat das ganze angefangen?
Lena Kuechler: Also ich bin vom persönlichen Standpunkt aus ja. Ich hab mich gemeldet in der Universität bei Professor Schumann und ich hab ihm gesagt, ich möchte weiter in der Psychologie arbeiten. Und das nur die Wissenschaft [unverständlich]. Ich hab alles verloren. [unverständlich] Hab ich nicht einmal erwartet. [unverständlich] Waren alle, auch die Professoren Antisemiten. Und von ihm hat man auch gesagt, dass er antisemitisch, aber es war nicht wahr. Er hat sich [unverständlich] gefreut, dass ich beim Leben geblieben [unverständlich].
David Boder: [In English] Ms. Kuechler requests that she would, Ms. Kuechler requests that she would want to talk in Polish, since that is her language, in which she can talk freely without any difficulty and that’s her specialty. I will endeavor to understand her and we are changing now to the second part of her career on the study of the children. We are changing to the Polish language.
David Boder: [In Russian] Говорите по-польски.
Lena Kuechler: [In Polish] Na uniwersytecie zaczęłam pracować naukowo. Pracowałam z wielkim zapałem. Dostałam pracę temat, który miałam opracować o zdolnościach konstrukcyjnych dzieci... i robiłam sama badania setek dzieci. Pierwszy rozdział tej pracy mnie specjalnie interesował, tam gdzieśmy mówili o pojęciu przestrzeni...
Lena Kuechler: [In German] Raumvorstellung bei Kindern...
Lena Kuechler: [In Polish] I te prace mają takie głębokie filozoficzne podłoże. Te rzeczy mnie bardzo, bardzo interesowały. Mogłam dużo dać z siebie. Pracowałam bardzo dużo, po szesnaście godzin dziennie. Pierwsze trzy miesiące pracowałam naukowo. Miałam odczyt na uniwersytecie w ścisłym kółku asystentów i rzeczoznawców... i profesor był z mojego odczytu zupełnie zadowolony. Zdołałam to zauważyć po tym, ponieważ potem dał mi szereg bardzo odpowiedzialnych prac.
David Boder: [In Russian] От чего вы жили?
Lena Kuechler: [In Polish] Mój brat miał dosyć wysokie stanowisko w rządzie polskim. Był szefem całej cenzury wojennej... i ja mieszkałam w jego mieszkaniu. Dużym, ładnym mieszkaniu... i także tam jadłam. To znaczy w biurze u niego jadłam, dlatego że oni tam mieli stołówkę, a poza tym ja żadnych nie miałam życzeń, nie miałam żadnych potrzeb, nic mię nie interesowało, nie zależało mi ani na ubraniu, ani na żadnych pieniądzach. Do dziś dnia mi nie zależy na tym wszystkim. Nie mam absolutnie żadnych potrzeb. Mam jedynie pewne potrzeby natury psychicznej. Wtedy chciałam zapomnieć o przeszłości. Chciałam pracować całą duszą tak, ażeby nie zostało mi nic czasu na myślenie i na wspomnienia. Ażebym mogła zapomnieć to wszystko, co straciłam, to wszystko, co przeżyłam w przeszłości, i na niczym więcej mi nie zależało... i byłabym dostała... tą pracę, którą robiłam o zdolnościach konstrukcyjnych... nazywaliśmy pracą doktorską, dlatego że ja mam dyplom magistra psychologii, ale nie zrobiłam jeszcze doktoratu i byłabym go skończyła, gdyby nie czysty przypadek. Byłabym tą pracę skończyła. Mianowicie przyszli do mnie z Komitetu Żydowskiego z prośbą, ażeby się zająć dziećmi, które teraz wracają z różnych obozów. Z Oświęcimia..., które przyprowadzają ludzie do Komitetu... i że dużo dzieci żydowskich zostało jeszcze przy życiu, że się włóczą, poniewierają, że nie mają dachu nad głową, że trzeba im coś stworzyć. Ażebym ja zorganizowała dom dla dzieci. Jeden z pierwszych domów w Polsce, ponieważ wtedy przeszłam pewną walkę psychiczną, dlatego że znalazłam dużo, duże zadowolenie w pracy naukowej. W ogóle praca naukowa jest dla mnie marzeniem. Jest moim ideałem. Jest tym, czego zawsze pragnęłam. Przed wojną nie mogłam dużo pracować naukowo, bo musiałam zarabiać na życie i byłam w złych stosunkach materialnych.
David Boder: [In Russian] Ага.
Lena Kuechler: [In Polish] A podczas wojny zupełnie nie mogłam pracować... i po wojnie, kiedy zostałam sama, bez rodziny, bez jakichkolwiek obowiązków, a sama nie miałam wielkich potrzeb, postanowiłam pracować naukowo... i teraz mnie znowu odrywają od tej pracy.
David Boder: [In Russian] Ага. Дальше...
Lena Kuechler: [In Polish] Wybrałam drogę pośrednią. Postanowiłam im tylko ten dom dziecka zorganizować. To znaczy pracować przez wakacje, przez lipiec i sierpień, a we wrześniu wrócić do mojej pracy naukowej na uniwersytecie... i taką umowę zrobiłam z prezesem Komitetu Żydowskiego w Krakowie, z doktorem [unintelligible]. Tymczasem, gdy tylko zaczęłam pracę z tymi dziećmi, już nie mogłam więcej się od nich oderwać. Moja obecność, obecność była konieczna, ażeby utrzymać dom. Mianowicie myśmy walczyli z ogromnymi trudnościami. Te dzieci, któreśmy dostali, które przyprowadzono do Komitetu, ja byłam od pierwszej chwili przy tym... były w okropnym stanie,... w okropnym, były tak wygłodzone, tak schorzałe, tak zawszawione, takie zaniedbane moralnie i fizycznie, i intelektualnie, że naprawdę ogromna praca stanęła przed nami. Poza tym nie mieliśmy w ogóle żadnych środków materialnych. Nie mieliśmy żadnego budżetu na to wszystko. Komitet Żydowski nie rozporządzał prawie żadnymi środkami materialnymi, a oblegany był codziennie przez całe masy rozmaitych ludzi, którzy wracali z obozu. Co można było dla tych ludzi zrobić, zaledwie zupkę im dać... i ci ludzie przeklinali nas wszystkich, a myśmy naprawdę nie mieli im, co dać. Rząd jeszcze wtedy w Polsce nie pracował, a te środki, cośmy otrzymywali od zubożałego rządu polskiego, to były minimalne. Zupełnie nie... nieproporcjonalne do potrzeb. Więc trzeba było... postanowiliśmy stworzyć dom w Zakopanem. Zakopane to jest miejscowość lecznicza, głównie dla dzieci chorych na płuca. Zakopane to jest miejscowość położona wśród gór, bardzo piękna miejscowość, ale znana ze swojego antysemityzmu jeszcze przed wojną. Tam wynajęto bardzo piękną willę, odrestaurowano ją, bo była zniszczona po Niemcach... i tam przyjechałam ja z pierwszą grupką dzieci. Dom był obiecany na sto dzieci... i zawsze miałam pełną liczbę dzieci, nawet jeszcze ich więcej. Był czas, kiedy miałam sto siedem dzieci, sto dziesięć dzieci. Oprócz tego przysyłano mi także i młodzież starszą, chorą na płuca, ludzi, którzy ocaleli z obozu, którzy... których trzeba było uratować. Byli tacy, którzy byli...
David Boder: [In Russian] Последнее предложение.
Lena Kuechler: [In Polish] ...więc posyłano mi ludzi, którzy byli chorzy na płuca, którzy przeszli przez kilka, nawet kilkanaście obozów, i których trzeba było ratować, więc tych ludzi oddawałam do sanatoriów polskich, ale dlatego że oni nie mogli, jako ciężko chorzy na płuca, być razem z dziećmi, ale tam w tych sanatoriach był straszny głód... i dlatego też myśmy im codziennie nosili od nas jedzenie... i w ogóle wszystkim się opiekowałam. Przynosiłam im bieliznę, kupowałam im lekarstwa, odwiedzałam ich... i mogę powiedzieć, że że kilku ludziom uratowałam życie... z tej młodzieży. Oprócz tego robiliśmy ogromną pracę z naszymi dziećmi. Bardzo mi ciężko było dostać personel. Nie było w ogóle ludzi. Nie było nikogo. Zebrałam pewną grupę kobiet, która wróciła z obozu Oświęcimia. Te kobiety straciły wszystkich. Straciły mężów, straciły dzieci swoje. Powiedziałam do nich parę słów. Powiedziałam im, że jeśli nie mają swoich własnych dzieci, ażeby te dzieci, które nie mają rodziców, żeby te dzieci przygarnąć do serca. Ażebyśmy się stały prawdziwymi matkami tych dzieci. Żebyśmy nie pracowały dla siebie, żebyśmy nie pracowały dla pieniędzy, żebyśmy nie pracowały zawodowo, poświęćmy się dla tych dzieci. To będzie cel naszego życia... i rzeczywiście cała nasza praca była jednym wielkim poświęceniem. Nasz dom nie był żadnym internatem. To nie był nawet dom dziecka, to była jedna wielka rodzina. Myśmy pracowali od rana do nocy. Męczyliśmy się strasznie. Ja się męczyłam ogromnie. Ja wciąż jeździłam. Ja nie miałam za co tych dzieci utrzymać. Komitet był stale w tarapatach pieniężnych, nigdy nie miał pieniędzy. Ja jeździłam do różnych ludzi prywatnych i prosiłam ich o pieniądze, ażeby dzieci utrzymać. Jeździłam do Jointy do Warszawy i tym nie wolno było nam dawać pieniędzy... i mimo wszystko dyrektor Jointy, Guzik, zawsze mi w jakiś sposób nielegalny, ale mi pomógł, żeby tych dzieci nie wyrzucić na ulicę. Co, co, co tydzień, co parę dni stawałam przed alternatywą zamknięcia domu... i tego, że dzieci się znajdą na ulicy, dlatego że nie wiedziałam w ogóle, jak przeżyjemy następny tydzień, w takich trudnościach pieniężnych byliśmy. Oprócz tego byliśmy otoczeni falą takiego antysemityzmu, że to się w ogóle nie da powiedzieć. Dzieci nie mogły w ogóle wychodzić na ulicę. Dostawały kamieniami w głowę. Jak trzech chłopców posłałam do kina, to siedzieli za nimi inni chłopcy polscy, którzy cały czas grozili im, że im wbiją nóż w plecy. Nie mogłam dzieci posłać do szkół polskich, dlatego że ich tam tak prześladowano i przezywano. Urzędnicy, ci niżsi urzędnicy aprowizacji nie chcieli nam dawać żadnych przydziałów. Chcieli nam jak najwięcej okroić. Nie miałam naprawdę tym dzieciom co dać jeść. Musiałam na wszystkie strony walczyć. Gdzie wychodziłam, tam słyszałam tylko okrzyki antysemickie. Byłam osobą znienawidzoną przez Polaków w Zakopanem. Dlatego że wszędzie broniłam naszych praw. W końcu widziałam, że ta fala antysemityzmu tak strasznie rośnie, a obok nas niedaleko był drugi dom dziecka w Rabce. To było jakieś trzydzieści kilometrów od nas. W Rabce były dzieci zupełnie chore. Tam było prewentorium. Ten dom dziecka w Rabce był trzy razy ostrzeliwany, bandyci, reakcja polska, NSZ...
David Boder: [In Russian] [unintelligible]
Lena Kuechler: [In Polish] Narodowe Siły Zbrojne polskie, to jest organizacja polska, która walczy z rządem polskim, a walczy na barkach sierot żydowskich, strzelając do nas. Ci napadli i rzucali granaty poprzez okno, przez okno do dzieci. Myśmy wtedy wszystkie dzieci, wszystkie dzieci wyciągnęli na korytarz i tam całą noc leżały. Trzy razy tak napadnięto, tydzień po tygodniu, na ten dom. Musieliśmy ten dom zlikwidować. Nie można go było utrzymać, nie mogliśmy narażać życia dzieci. Przypuszczaliśmy, że ta fala przeniesie się do Zakopanego. I dlatego też ja postanowiłam uprzedzić to wszystko i zorganizować naszą obronę. Udałam się do władz bezpieczeństwa i do policji polskiej... i postanowiłam zorganizować obronę... i zorganizowałam ją w następujący sposób. Dostałam dziesięciu ludzi do obrony... [unintelligible]
Lena Kuechler: [In Polish] ...karabin maszynowy zainstalowaliśmy na jednej z werand. Oprócz tego miałam syrenę alarmową, miałam reflektory, miałam telefon.
David Boder: [In Russian] [unintelligible]
Lena Kuechler: [In Polish] Zupełnie jak w obozie koncentracyjnym... i wszyscy mieli granaty i... jak się nazywa to... urządzenia...
Lena Kuechler: [In Polish] ...najrozmaitszego rodzaju broń, ażeby bronić się. Ja sama mimo wszystko, że nam rząd dał tych żołnierzy, pierwszej nocy zaraz, kiedy oni nas mieli bronić, to były dwie partie, mianowicie byli tam milicjanci i byli z bezpieczeństwa publicznego, to milicjanci się pobili z tymi milicjantami z bezpieczeństwa publicznego i obrzucali się nawzajem granatami u mnie w domu, przy dzieciach. Taką miałam obronę. Wobec tego wszystkiego zrozumiałam, że to nie są ludzie, na których polegać można, i postanowiłam znaleźć Żydów, którzy nas bronić będą, i ja sama dostałam pozwolenie na broń. Umiałam się obchodzić z rewolwerem i ja sama nocami czuwałam i broniłam domu. I rzeczywiście był na nas napad, który jednak odparliśmy. Napad zaczął się od ostrzeliwań, coraz to bardziej się zbliżali ci. Strzelali do nas. Jednakże myśmy natychmiast ten atak odparli, strzelaliśmy na wszystkie strony i dostaliśmy pomoc. Zrobiliśmy wielki ruch, tak że oni wszyscy odeszli. Ale takie rzeczy zdarzały się już potem też. Poczem na mnie samą był napad. Tylko nie wiadomo dokładnie, jaki był, czy to był bardziej, miał charakter polityczny czy rabunkowy, dlatego że raz, kiedy wracałam do domu o szóstej wieczorem, nawet niedaleko mojego domu. Już zaczęło się ściemniać. Napadło na mnie dwóch osobników z rewolwerem i obrabowało mnie. Zabrali mi wtedy kilkanaście tysięcy złotych i pobili mnie bardzo. Byłam posiniaczona na całym ciele i poraniona. Skrępowali mnie, rzucili mnie na ziemie i pobili mnie. Wtedy nie miałam broni przy sobie, bo bym się była broniła, a oni dwaj osobnicy byli uzbrojeni. Przypuszczam jednak, że ten napad był, tak jak wszystkie napady w Polsce, polityczny i rabunkowy. Że oni dokładnie wiedzieli, kim ja jestem i... bo gdyby to był tylko napad rabunkowy, nie byliby mnie pobili tak ostro. Więc dzieci, które zebrałam, pochodzą z rozmaitych środowisk. [unintelligible] Więc tak, duża część pochodzi z lasu. Głównie starsi chłopcy i starsze dziewczynki, starsze to są u mnie szesnastoletnie, szesnasto-, piętnastoletnie dzieci. Ta partyzantka miała głównie miejsce na wschodzie Polski. Więc mam na przykład tutaj chłopca, który się nazywa Natan [unintelligible], który sam będzie mógł tutaj mówić zresztą, który walczył na tyłach armii niemieckiej. Walczył razem z partyzantką rosyjską. Był w lesie, przez dwa lata, i miał tam dopiero wtedy jedenaście lat, dostał konia, i kilku takich chłopców miałam, którzy w ustach trzymali uzdę, lejce, a w rękach rewolwer i na koniu walczyli. Ci chłopcy naturalnie głodowali tak jak wszyscy żołnierze, następnie robili wypady na... wypady z lasu, więc podkładali miny pod mosty, wysadzali mosty, następnie gdy wiedzieli, że armia...
David Boder: [In Russian] [unintelligible]
Lena Kuechler: [In Polish] ...nie to było w czasie wojny, to byli partyzanci,... więc podkładali miny pod mosty, następnie w lesie, gdy wiedzieli, że armia przejdzie, to też rozkręcali szyny i tak dalej... więc chłopcy, ...dużo miałam takich chłopców, którzy walczyli w partyzantce. Przeszli oni bardzo dużo. Ci chłopcy teraz zgłosili się do Komitetu Żydowskiego. Część dzieci była u chłopów. Dzieci te przeżyły... chłopi nie wiedzieli, że to są dzieci żydowskie. Dzieci te bardzo ciężko pracowały. Byli pastuchami, byli parobkami, paśli krowy, konie i prowadzili całe gospodarstwo. Pracowali bardzo ciężko i bardzo głodowali. Część dzieci była pochowana w rozmaitych kryjówkach. Mam dzieci takie, które siedziały w kryjówkach, siedziały w szafach. Mam jedną dziewczynkę, która siedziała dwa i pół roku w szafie. Malutkie dziecko. Trzechletnie. Dziecko to zupełnie nie umiało mówić ani chodzić, kiedy wyszło z tej szafy, było zupełnie zagłodzone i zawszawione. Dziecko to z trudem wyciągnęliśmy z tej szafy, dlatego że ta opiekunka, która ją miała w szafie... w Warszawie to było, odeszła z tego pokoju, zamknęła drzwi na klucz i nie wróciła więcej, i dziecko tam już dwa dni było bez jedzenia, a potem myśmy się o tym dowiedzieli i wyciągnęliśmy to dziecko przez okno. Mam dzieci, które siedziały w kryjówkach po rok i dwa lata z podwiniętymi nogami, tak że jak później wyszli z tych kryjówek, to mieli zupełną atrofię mięśni w nogach, nie umieli zupełnie chodzić. Część dzieci przechowała się w klasztorach polskich, ale w tych klasztorach te dzieci zostały przechrzczone i ci księża później nie chcieli tych dzieci wydawać, tylko w niektórych żłobkach, gdzie panował straszny głód, gdzie nie mieli, co dzieciom dać jeść, też polskim dzieciom, to przede wszystkim chcieli się pozbyć żydowskich dzieci i przyprowadzili je do Komitetu. Ja pracowałam początkowo w Komitecie, gdzie te dzieci przychodziły, i sama byłam niejeden raz świadkiem tej sceny. Oprócz tego myśmy... początkowo przyprowadzano nam dzieci tak bezinteresownie, bo się chciano pozbyć tych dzieci. Potem zrozumiano, że należy żądać pieniędzy za to, że Żydzi mają przecież dużo pieniędzy, więc żądano opłat za te dzieci. Potem coraz większych opłat żądano, a potem nawet posyłano dzieci, żeby dzieci szantażowały nas, to znaczy, że posyłano dzieci i dzieci żądały dla swoich opiekunów polskich pieniędzy. Płakały nam cały dzień, męczyły nas, grozili nam i tak dalej, ażebyśmy im te pieniądze dawali.
David Boder: [In Russian] А скажите, эти монастыри... это были женские монастыри или мужские?
Lena Kuechler: [In Polish] To byli rozmaici, głównie te mniejsze dzieci były w klasztorach. Tak na przykład mogę opowiedzieć historię o pięciu dzieciach, które my nazywamy Bobolakami. To są... Bobolakami nazywamy je. To są czarujące dzieci. Te dzieci mają od trzech do pięciu lat.
David Boder: [In German] [unintelligible]
Lena Kuechler: [In Polish] Jak byłam w Warszawie...
Lena Kuechler: [unintelligible]
Lena Kuechler: [In Polish] ...klasztor imieniem świętego Andrzeja Boboli.
David Boder: [In Russian] О! И как вы называли детей?
Lena Kuechler: [In Polish] ...i te dzieci nazwaliśmy potem Bobolakami.
David Boder: [In Russian] [unintelligible]
Lena Kuechler: [In Polish] Święty Andrzej Bobola, tak. Więc te dzieci... ja, będąc w Warszawie, dowiedziałam się przypadkowo od jakiegoś lekarza, że znalazł jakieś dzieci obrzezane. Malutkie dzieci w jakimś klasztorze Boboli... i że to ma być w pobliżu Zakopanego. Ponieważ nie mogłam się z tym człowiekiem... nie mogłam się dowiedzieć, który to był lekarz... i kto to powiedział i gdzie to było, więc zaczęłam szukać na własną rękę tych dzieci. Poszłam do dziekana do kościoła i chciałam się dowiedzieć, gdzie tu jest jakiś zakład, albo klasztor w imieniu świętego Andrzeja Boboli, ale dziekan mi nic nie powiedział. Powiedział, że nie wie. Nie wiem, czy nie chciał mi odpowiedzieć, czy też rzeczywiście nie wiedział. Wobec tego zaczęłam wszystkie zakony, wszystkie zakłady, domy dziecka w pobliżu Zakopanego i w samym Zakopanem i w Poroninie objeżdżać i dowiadywać się, gdzie jest taki zakład, i w końcu wpadłam na trop takiego zakładu, i tam przyszłam i jakkolwiek nic nie wiedziałam dokładnie, powiedziałam im, że dowiedziałam się, że tu są dzieci żydowskie. Ci ludzie początkowo się nie chcieli przyznać, ale w końcu mi powiedziano tak, że jest tutaj dwóch, trzech, chłopców małych, którzy pochodzą z getta żydowskiego. Więc opowiedziano mi, że te dzieci były... jak to getto likwidowano... jak się getto paliło, to te dzieci znaleziono na ulicy, to były maleńkie dzieci, to były jeszcze niemowlęta w poduszce, i te dzieci zostały wyniesione w plecaku, w tornistrze z getta, przez policjantów, i oddane do zakładu Boduena. To był taki żłobek imieniem księdza Boduena w Warszawie... i tam w tym żłobku te dzieci się chowały. Źle było bardzo tym dzieciom, bo tam w ogóle warunki nie były dobre, a jeszcze tym bardziej w czasie wojny. Potem, kiedy Warszawa była bombardowana, ewakuowano ten cały dom i między... i te dzieci porozdzielano na prowincje, i te dzieci oddano do klasztoru, do zakładu katolickiego imieniem świętego Andrzeja Boboli, tu w Zakopanem. Zakład zrobił na mnie wrażenie okropne. Ciemny, brudny. Bardzo dużo malutkich dzieci, wszystkie ogolone do skóry, wszystkie w pasiakach, w takich... jednakowo ubrane. Gdy przyszłam do tych dzieci, przyniosłam im ze sobą ciastka i cukierki. Przełożona pozwoliła mi, ażebym sama rozdzieliła te cukierki dzieciom. Gdy pokazałam się z tymi cukierkami u dzieci, dzieci te na mnie tak strasznie napadły i tak okropnie krzyczały, i jedne dzieci płakały, jedno dziecko deptało po drugim i jedno odpychało drugie, że zupełnie te dzieci przyparły mnie do muru i przełożona mnie musiała uratować. A to były wszystkie dzieci od dwóch do pięciu lat, takie maleńkie dzieci. Tam było gdzieś osiemdziesiąt takich małych dzieci. Wszystkie w jednej sali. Byłam bardzo zrozpaczona, gdy to widziałam. Zrozumiałam, że te dzieci były bardzo wygłodzone wszystkie, że one nigdy nie widzą cukierków, że pierwszy raz może widziały cukierki, i były... i dlatego tak się rzuciły i te dzieci są zupełnie dzikie z głodu. Bardzo mi było żal tych dzieci. Prosiłam, ażeby mi siostra przełożona pokazała te żydowskie dzieci. Pokazała mi te dzieci. Najpierw tylko trzech chłopców. Zauważyłam, że byli oni mniejsi i jeszcze gorzej wyglądali niż inne dzieci. Sama siostra powiedziała mi, że dziwi się bardzo, ale rzeczywiście te żydowskie dzieci się gorzej chowają niż inne. Następnie powiedziała mi, że ona mi tych dzieci nie wyda bez specjalnego zezwolenia z gminy miasta w Warszawie. Wobec tego posłałam jedną panią do Warszawy. Nie pojechałam sama, dlatego że ja miałam wyjechać za trzy dni już z wszystkimi dziećmi do Francji. To było... bardzo mało mieliśmy czasu, ale dałam jej adresy moich dobrych znajomych, którzy załatwią tą sprawę, ażeby dać zezwolenie wyciągnięcia tych dzieci. Ta pani bez chwili namysłu w pół godziny później pojechała do Warszawy... i do Warszawy się jechało dwadzieścia dwie godziny. W okropnych warunkach. Dwadzieścia dwie godziny tam i dwadzieścia dwie godziny z powrotem. Zupełnie dwie doby nie spała i przywiozła mi to zezwolenie. Następnie wystarałam się o pieniądze, prywatne, i wzięłam z mojego magazynu, ile mogłam, produktów na furę i pojechałam tam do nich z pieniędzmi, z produktami i z tym zezwoleniem. Te zakonnice były bardzo zdumione, że to tak szybko się stało, nie spodziewały się, że ja dostanę zezwolenie, dlatego że nie było tak łatwo te rzeczy dostać, a ja załatwiłam to, dlatego że miałam dużo znajomości w rządzie polskim w Warszawie. No i potem broniły się, prosiły, że później oddadzą, że ksiądz się sprzeciwia, ponieważ te dzieci są przechrzczone, że to są już dzieci katolickie, że my zrobimy znowu z nich żydów, że... bronili się, jak mogli, następnie mówili mi, że te dzieci są brudne, że oni je najpierw wymyją, że najpierw je wykąpią, że najpierw je wyczeszą... ja jednak prosiłam ich, żeby mi od razu te dzieci oddano, z tego powodu... i że my już się tymi dziećmi zajmiemy, że my je wymyjemy i wykąpiemy, i ponieważ przywiozłam ze sobą tyle podarunków dla dzieci, tyle jedzenia i pieniądze, i zezwolenie... i wszystko razem, wobec tego wszystkiego oni już nie mogli się bronić i jednak mi te dzieci oddali. Wtedy saniami przywiozłam tą piątkę dzieci na rękach sama. Jak przywiozłam tę piątkę dzieci i pokazałam te dzieci moim dzieciom, tym, które już dawno miałam, to wszystkie dzieci płakały. Tak te dzieci wyglądały. Wszystkie były boso, a to było w lutym, w zimie głębokiej. A zima w Zakopanem jest bardzo ostra. Żadne nie miało bucików, nie miało płaszczyka, były obwiązane w łachmanach... obwiązane. Dzieci były wszystkie poprzeziębiane, wszystkie moczyły się. Wszystkie ogolone do skóry, chude takie, że tylko skóra i kości. Cały czas płakały. Straszliwie się wszystkiego bały. Bały się konia, bały się psa, bały się kota, bały się w ogóle ludzi. Jak mówiono coś do nich, to dostawały szoku. Zaczynały krzyczeć ze strachu. W ogóle nie znały mięsa, nigdy w życiu nie jadły mięsa. Nie znały czekolady, nie znały cukierków. Nigdy nic słodkiego w ustach nie miały. Nie umieli w ogóle jeść tych rzeczy. Karmiono je tylko kartoflami i czasami jakąś kaszą i czarną kawą. Te dzieci miały po dwa, trzy lata i nigdy nie wychodziły na ulicę. Wcale nie wychodziły, ponieważ nie miały ubrania, a w Zakopanem jest długi czas zima. Dzieci były zupełnie dzikie. Nie wierzyłam nawet, że z tych dzieci coś będzie, przypuszczałam, że na tą były dwie dziewczynki i trzej chłopcy. Oprócz tego miały skrofuły i chore były. Przypuszczałam, że nie wychowają się. Myślałam, że przynajmniej dwójka, trójka na pewno mi umrze. Niemniej moje dzieci i my wszyscy razem otoczyłyśmy te dzieci naprawdę opieką. Dzieci im przynosiły wszystko, co tylko miały, jabłka, czekoladę, oddawały im całe swoje jedzenie. Od razu nazwaliśmy ich Bobolakami, bawili ich, tańczyli, śpiewali im, kołysali, nosili na rękach. Każdy nosił te dzieci. Niestety mieliśmy bardzo mało czasu, żeby te dzieci,... żeby te dzieci jakoś pielęgnować, bośmy zaraz się wybrali w drogę do Francji. A ta droga była bardzo ciężka i trwała trzy tygodnie. Z Zakopanego do Paryża, dlatego że myśmy jechali... przeszli granicę polską nielegalnie i w ogóle walczyliśmy z różnymi trudnościami. Niemniej te dzieci teraz są czarujące. Szkoda... będę mogła przekazać fotografie tych dzieci. Te dzieci są tłuste, jeden z tych chłopczyków, jak przyszedł do mnie, miał siedem kilo. Teraz ma piętnaście kilogramów. To są dzieci bardzo inteligentne, bardzo mądre i bardzo piękne. Wszystkie, którzy przyjeżdżają tutaj do nas, chcą mi zabrać te dzieci, ale nie mogę tych dzieci oddać. Specjalnie się przywiązałam i wszyscy jesteśmy przywiązani. To są... te dzieci są jakby naszą własnością. Są własnością całego narodu żydowskiego. Uważam, że ich miejsce jest w Palestynie.
David Boder: [In Russian] Вы о Палестине говорили, да?
Lena Kuechler: [In Polish] Tak, te dzieci rozwijają się przepięknie u nas. Niemniej są takie stare schorzenia jeszcze, z którymi musimy... które musimy tutaj likwidować. Tak że na przykład dwie dziewczynki, które mamy, są teraz w szpitalu. Jedna ma wciąż chore oczy, a druga ma parch. To jest jedyny wypadek i bardzo ciężki wypadek. Włosy całe jej wylatują, a chłopcy, których tu mamy, trzej chłopcy chowają nam się doskonale. Dwaj z nich są wybitnie inteligentni. Przepięknie się rozwijają, są bardzo ładni i bardzo dobrali na wadze i ślicznie się rozwijają. Taka jest historia naszych pięciu dzieci zwanych Bobolaków. Wszyscy bardzo ich kochamy, to są najmłodsze nasze dzieci i to są dosłownie nasze dzieci. Te dzieci wszystkie wołają na mnie mama i ponieważ nie znają pojęcia słowa matki i czują, że je kocham bardzo, więc dobrze jest im u nas. Pieścimy je, są troszeczkę rozpieszczane, ale nie możemy się oprzeć ich urokowi. Wszystkie dzieci inne mają to poczucie właśnie, że widziały od pierwszej chwili, jak te dzieci wyglądały, jak teraz wyglądają, codziennie się je obserwuje, jak się przepięknie rozwijają u nas i dlatego tak bardzo jesteśmy do tych dzieci przywiązani. To jest historia jednej piątki, ale każde z naszych dzieci ma taką tragiczną historię. Każda dziewczynka, każdy chłopczyk. Każdy z nich przeszedł całe piekło. Tu by trzeba tony całe pisać, a nie jeden wywiad, ażeby, ażeby to wszystko o tych dzieciach powiedzieć.
David Boder: [In Russian] А какие планы теперь насчет детей? Когда, вы думаете, удастся их перевезти... перевезти в Палестину?
Lena Kuechler: [In Polish] My byśmy bardzo chcieli wszyscy jechać do Palestyny i głębokim naszym życzeniem jest, ażebyśmy dalej zostali wszyscy razem, dlatego że my tworzymy jedną rodzinę. To nie jest dom, to nie jest internat, to jest jedna rodzina. Mój stosunek do dzieci... do tych wszystkich dzieci jest taki jak stosunek matki do swoich własnych rodzonych dzieci. Może nawet jeszcze... jeszcze głębszy. Bronię tych dzieci i będę ich broniła, jak długo one będą ze mną... zawsze. Chciałabym być... zostać z nimi na zawsze. Chciałabym dożyć tego, żeby te dzieci wyszły za mąż, żebym już miała moje własne wnuki. Nie mam swojej własnej rodziny. Nie mam nikogo tutaj, mam brata, który został w Polsce, tylko, ale który ma swoją pracę ideową. On jest komunistą, a ja nie. Ja jestem syjonistką. My się różnimy. Moją całą rodziną są te dzieci tutaj... jest ten dom. Nie chciałabym się z nimi już rozłączać. Dzieci między sobą są równie zżyte bardzo. Kochają się bardzo. Stosunek wzajemny ich jest taki jak brata do siostry. Starsze dzieci pieszczą i bawią młodsze dzieci. Jak na przykład poszliśmy raz na wycieczkę, na plażę, i musieliśmy parę kilometrów pieszo chodzić, to dzieci prosiły, żeby tych malutkich, tych Bobolaków, które nie umieją chodzić pieszo, też zabrać. Żeby one nie zostały same w domu. Żeby nie płakały. Że oni ich nosić będą... i każdy duży chłopiec i dziewczynka duża wzięła na plecy małe dziecko... i taki pochód szedł przez ulice francuskiego miasteczka tak, że ludzie widzieli to i śmiali się z nas, ale to jest bardzo wzruszające. Dlatego, że to wykazuje, jak bardzo te starsze dzieci są przywiązane do młodszych, jak je bardzo kochają. W ogóle już niejedną próbę przeszliśmy, która nam wykazała, że poczucie solidarności i przynależności wzajemnej jest u naszych dzieci bardzo mocne, że się bardzo wszyscy nawzajem kochają. Jeżeli się czasem sprzeczają z sobą, to tak się sprzeczają, jak się sprzecza brat z siostrą, bo to też bywa w domu rodzinnym. Pragniemy żyć w Palestynie. Wszystkie dzieci tego pragną... i my też, a ja najgoręcej. Mamy dosyć wędrówki, mamy dosyć poniewierki. Nie chcemy, ażeby nam już... żeby nas przezywano od żydów. Chcemy być dumni z tego... jesteśmy dumni z tego, że jesteśmy Żydami. Chcemy żyć w naszym własnym kraju. Na naszej własnej ziemi. Chcemy być obywatelami własnego kraju, chcemy się rozwijać wolno i swobodnie. Nie ważne jest dla nas jak tam jest..., że tam są ciężkie warunki bytu, niż na przykład we Francji. Nie ważne jest dla nas to, że tam jest teraz ciężko, że tam jest teraz walka. My chcemy walczyć o naszą ojczyznę, o nasz kraj. Pragniemy być na własnej ziemi. Straciliśmy wszystko. Nie mamy rodziny, nie mamy rodziców, nie mamy dzieci, nie mamy żon. Dzieci nie mają swoich rodziców. Pragniemy mieć naszą swoją własną ziemię. To jest dla nas nasz cel. Dzieci się uczą dużo po hebrajsku i dlatego, że wiedzą o tym, że to jest ich język rodzinny, i wszystkie marzą o tym, żeby się dostać do Palestyny. Ja prosiłam o to, żeby jak najszybciej nam przydzielić certyfikaty. Drogą nielegalną nie chcielibyśmy się dostać do Palestyny i nie możemy się dostać, bo mamy malutkie dzieci z sobą, które nie możemy narażać na obozy koncentracyjne, bo te dzieci dosyć już przeszły i te dzieci nie są bardzo zdrowe... i dlatego chcielibyśmy dostać certyfikaty. Obiecano nam jak najszybciej certyfikaty. Niestety to nie zależy od nas, tylko od sytuacji politycznej. Jak będą tylko certyfikaty, mam nadzieję, że w pierwszym rzędzie nasza grupa dostanie. Chciałabym jeszcze zaznaczyć, że wszystkie moje dzieci są całkowite prawie sieroty. Jest tylko kilkoro dzieci, które odnalazło matkę albo ojca. Ale ten ojciec jest albo w Szanghaju...
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool 115 taken at Bellevue. Interview with Ms. Lena Kuechler, in charge of a group of children which, about 60, which were taken out from Poland, by her and some 10 collaborators and are now awaiting certification to go to Palestine. The children are from the age of 3 to 15. This concludes Spool number 115. Illinois Institute of Technology wire re... [ends abruptly].